- So wait, what are your
kids into these days?
- Slime, which we were
talking about backstage.
My son is just an avid baseball player.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's cool.
- Yeah, which is amazing.
And also, he plays the
guitar and the drums.
- Yeah.
- My daughter's very into fashion.
I noticed.
- She's also really into,
yes, she's also really into holidays,
like the kid has never met
a holiday she doesn't love.
- Like in decorating and stuff.
- Everything.
- That's me.
- That's you?
- I love it.
And my son, actually, my
six-year-old son loves it.
- Oh, that's sweet.
Yeah, my son doesn't care.
- He literally tells me to
stop and move out of the way
'cause I am in the way
of his decorating dream,
like his vision.
- I love that.
- Yeah, my daughter, meanwhile,
is off watching YouTube.
- My daughter said to me the other night,
I got into bed with
her and she said, "Mom,
the love fairy paid a
visit to your office."
- The love fairy?
- I said, "What's the love fairy?"
She goes, "You know, for Valentine's Day."
- Did she decorate your office?
- She decorated my office.
But she didn't have decorations,
so they're all just kind of handmade.
- [Kelly] Which is way better!
- [Alyssa] Look at how cute.
I love you, look.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- [Alyssa] I made these.
- I made this, M-A-I-D,
I love it, I love it.
So my favorite part of this picture
is yes, your daughter is wonderful,
but also, you are a
beverage queen like me.
You have cold and hot,
it looks like.
- That's right!
That's exactly right.
- That's me, too.
- That's exactly right,
'cause you just never know.
- You just never know, and
sometimes I like to mix it up
and get crazy.
- And if I'm on a Zoom,
like sometimes I wanna
be cool with my coffee.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- And other times I wanna look kind of
like healthy and sporty
so I have my water.
- Oh, see mine is like
I just don't know what the hell I want.
That's mine.
So, I'm like I just like the options.
- Mine are props.
- Oh mine are totally
like I just don't know
what I'm gonna be in the mood for
and I'm gonna be trapped
here for a minute,
so I just start getting,
yeah, I get, do you get that on planes?
I get that on planes,
I'm like, oh my god, I'm stuck here.
I freak out, like I'm
not gonna be able to,
what do I need?
And then I bring way too much on a plane.
- Oh, yeah, then you
gotta get all settled.
- Why did I bring seven books?
I can't even finish one on this flight.
Why did I?
Because I don't know which
one I'm gonna want to read.
- That is so me.
And you know what else I started doing
is bringing cleaning supplies.
- Yeah.
Well, that's COVID got us.
- I wipe down everything now.
- [Kelly] You're my sister.
- Yeah.
- She travels with like a bag.
- It's just a bag.
- Like Mary Poppins of cleaning, yeah.
She's been like that since
before COVID, it's a problem.
But if you ever need
anything, she's there for you.
- She's there, she's got it.
- She's got it covered.